bonjour à tous et bon jour chef bien un
jour alors chez eux
qu'allez-vous de me tenir jeudi et bien
plus que ça va me laisser toutes les
sauces nous allons apprendre à cuisiner
je parle bien sûr de vos formes aux
querelles et de cannelle c'est
basiquement deux le haut des oeufs de la
farine du beurre et de la vienne deux
pour le bout seulement pour les boues
vraiment et non pas uniquement certes un
petit cours une gastronomie moléculaire
la viande si les muscles et dans les
muscles il ya des protéines de l'aqtim
et de la myosine lakhtine et la myosine
souris prod in responsable de la
contraction musculaire
les textes de la myosine celui et
s'articule naturellement finalement
aqtim quand on leur apporte de l'énergie
sous forme de chaleur par exemple
ainsi les protéines musculaires
s'agglomèrent à plus basse température
que celle du blanc d'oeuf
ces molécules s'agglomèrent avec
l'accusé et vont agir comme agent jenny
fiom de votre que l mais l'émissaire
répartie se marrer les protéines
c'est pourquoi je vous conseille de
faire o'connell au mortier comme le veut
l'antique tradition des querelles à
française
les cugnalais la français sont bien
réveillés et c'est pas dieu d'eau qui
nous contredira est pour mais je vais le
bol un petit collège à la porte de la
cuisine moléculaire
je t'aime petit gars qui sort et des
sculptures